shanxi and the legend of the ten rings
tells a complete self-contained origin
story while also setting up future
adventures in the marvel cinematic
universe not everything is neatly tied
up at the end of the story here are some
of the biggest unanswered questions left
open by shang chi
perhaps the worst kept secret about
shang chi and the legend of the ten
rings was the involvement of ben
kingsley as trevor slattery who first
entered the marvel cinematic universe in
2013's iron man 3. i wouldn't go in
there for 20 minutes
if ben kingsley's red carpet arrivals
didn't make it clear his surprise
appearance at the chongqi press
conference solidified it his role wasn't
a mere bit part either trevor proved
critical to the plot and our heroes
could never have found talo without him
while the audience sees what happens to
shanghai katie and xia ling trevor just
kind of vanishes he survives the attack
of these so-called soul suckers by
playing dead which might be the greatest
performance of the desperate actor's
career but what about us the audience we
never learn if he stayed in the village
if he left with chongqi and the gang or
began his own acting troupe among the
residents of tallow sir ben kingsley is
one of the best parts of the film so
here's hoping we don't have to wait
another seven years to find out what
happened to him and you'll never see me
coming
one of the last things we hear before
the credits roll is that xiaoling is at
her father's base to dismantle his
operations then the post-credits scene
reveals that xiaoling did indeed show up
at the ten ring space but most certainly
did not dismantle it instead she takes
the throne herself as men and women
train in the courtyard seemingly
preparing themselves to take down
whatever targets shaolin may select we
are promised the ten rings will return
which means that one way or another
we'll get a definitive answer to what
xiaoling plans on doing with her new
crew we don't know whether she was
always lying about taking apart her
dad's toxic infrastructure or if she
just had a potentially sinister change
of heart we also don't know how noble
she'll be in her new role although her
story in chiang chi seemed to end in a
positive place she's still now lost both
of her parents there's no telling how
that may have affected her outlook did
shelling's underground fighting outfit
at the golden daggers club get folded
into this new business venture we'll
have to wait to find out
and katie are best friends and have such
natural chemistry that katie's own
grandmother asks when the two are going
to get married at no point in the movie
is any kind of romantic relationship
discussed or even really implied between
them and yet their story still follows
something resembling a traditional
friends to lovers arc the only thing is
they never officially become lovers by
the end of the movie they are walking
arm-in-arm with each other and certainly
seem closer than when they started is
that the only hint we get about their
relationship status what exactly is
their deal zhang chi and the legend of
the ten rings director destin daniel
[ __ ] addressed this point during a
shang-chi press conference attended by
looper when asked if shang-chi and katie
were meant to be best friends or
potential love interests he asked aren't
all friendships potential love interests
he went on to say that the relationship
between chongqi and katie was written as
being intimate caring but also strictly
platonic but he also said there's
another reason why sean and katie don't
end their adventure with a big romantic
smooch as the director put it it also
just naturally felt like the only way to
go with this movie because chongqi is so
deep in his own inner struggle i don't
think there's emotional space for
anything else what's left unanswered is
what happens next after all shang chi's
arc in the movie is him finally coming
to terms with his upbringing and inner
turmoil now that he's got a little more
emotional space will these two stay
friends forever or become something more
fittingly shang chi in the legend of the
ten rings begins with a legend we start
with the story of wen wu using his
powers to conquer his enemies while the
narration speculates about the origin of
the rings possibilities like the rings
being found in a cave are mentioned but
nothing has ever declared the truth and
that's the sum total of what we know
about the mcu official origins of his
power in the comics the rings arrived on
earth many years ago with finn fang fume
the extraterrestrial shape-shifting
lizard dragon alien thing who may or may
not be present in chongqi in the form of
the giant monster that kills wenwu the
mandarin tore his spaceship apart
looking for artifacts and that's how he
got his ten rings but none of this is
mentioned in the movie and we are told
that when wu aka the mandarin has
possessed these rings for 10 lifetimes
so were they the result of some kind of
11th century treasure hunt was when wu
seeking them out we know at the end that
the rings have some kind of beacon were
they reaching out to him or were they
reaching out to somewhere in outer space
calling for some alien force to come to
earth and come after them it's almost
certain that we'll learn more about the
lineage of the ten rings at some point
but as for how when wu found them in the
first place that remains to be seen
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
chongqi and the legend of the ten rings
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you